on a maintenant quatre îles avec le
président du parti la dissidence
française le grand remplacement
vous dites est une réalité je milite
pour la remise gracieuse lors absolument
expliquez-nous vous vous êtes où vous
êtes donc il faut bien sur l'immigration
will et l'arrêt du ravel à réduire ou la
selas l'agent vous paraissez sympathie
non non non je faisais engueuler parce
que j'ai pas dit oui sous les ombrages
de design du bien aux migrations là
forcément on est encore sur un autre
label donc je peux parler jeudi matin de
le faire en fait c'est ça qui me dit
évoquant à l'époque l'a donc
concrètement déjà faut admettre une
réalité contrairement aux chiffres
avancés qui sont des chiffres faux parce
qu'en face aux stars actuelles vous
aider c'est factuel vous donner deux
chiffres mais ces chiffres du bien ça
l'intérieur d'accord pour aller 70 150
mosquées en france
d'accord 2015 2400 mosquée toujours
c'est ce que pensent les musulmans nous
dit l'immigration c'est formidable tout
va très bien et c'est le premier de
sujets de préoccupation des français ce
qu'est d'accord j'ai eu quelques
attentats il ya une délinquance
endémique
il ya eu des centaines de morts des
milliers de blessés dont les attentats
c'est pas ma part ça quoi faire valoir
et l'immigration pas si je vois pas le
rapport
immigration
c'est toujours du tout le monde est
toujours tout à fait d'accord pour
accueillir et orléans et c'est
effectivement on a les levine un rôle à
on est les méchants fachos on est ainsi
tout ce que vous voulez sauf que
abandonné un peu c'est vrai taisez vous
devez d'abord on a demandé l'avis pour
imposer à quel moment on a fait un
référendum sur l'immigration pour leur
dire voilà on va accueillir 16 millions
d'immigrés qui partage avec vous ni la
lancée des lions michèle tribalat 2
millions soit l'âge et les chiens c'est
pas idiot du chiffre et c'est oui mais
arrête tout nous avec la savoie sur les
jeux wii et wii mais c'est très
important
c'était à migration n'a jamais demandé
aux français s'ils étaient d'accord ou
pas pour vivre ensemble on disait l'ex
géant semble méritée est ce qu'on leur a
demandé l'avis aux français à aucun
moment il ya des élections élections les
élections et bien que forcément saisi
vincent bien sûr moi je joue quand même
ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est pourquoi
les européens devraient être les seuls
en permanence à devoir accueillir toute
la misère
il ya une autre vision
laissez moi parler baisse va parler
vincent là vous dites de mort là vous
dit une bêtise il n'ya pas qu'il ait pas
de l'immigration qu'en europe on avait
écouté mes séries il ya une frontière
entre la syrie et l'arabie saoudite
cette fois l'arabie saoudite est un pays
riche du sang dans le pays où ça va très
vite
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'il vous réponde on veut pas
d'eux des milliers de migrants chez nous
se protéger